متعب
[موسيقى]
أعتقد أنها أكبر مجموعة في
العالم في الواقع وكما ذكرت
ما يقرب من 10000 مخ تم جمعها
من عام 1945 إلى 1980 في أوائل الثمانينيات وتم
جمعها من قبل طبيب نفسي دنماركي بارز جدًا ،
كما قام بتوسيعها في جميع
المنازل
[الموسيقى]
كان للمرضى الأجانب [الموسيقى] في الطب النفسي عدد قليل جدًا من
الحقوق التي يمكن أن تجعلك تعرف
الحصول على العلاج دون أن
تقول نعم لهذا
العلاج المعين ، وكان يُنظر إلى المرضى
على أنهم ليسوا على قدم المساواة مع الدنماركيين الآخرين  في ذلك
الوقت
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى] أجنبية
عندما لم يتم التعامل مع ذلك
بالمعاملة التي لدينا الآن ولكنهم بهذا
المعنى يسمح لنا بالنظر إلى
التغييرات لأنه عندما ننظر إلى
أدمغتنا بالطبع
قد تكون التغييرات  يكون أيضًا نتيجة
للعلاج الذي
تلقاه هؤلاء المرضى ،
وعندما نقارن ربما مع
أدمغة بنك الدماغ ، يمكننا أن
نرى ما إذا كانت هذه التغييرات يمكن أن
ترتبط بالعلاج أم لا لأن
تلك الأدمغة لم يتم علاجها
من الخارج